I did a lot of weird I likes old  time-life books over the phone  I sold steaks which Omaha Steaks is  where I worked yeah it would be a lot of  me is that like how do you how do you  sell that mine was easier I would call  and my main thing it's so stupid I would  take a piece of paper and this was like  my closer I would wiggle the piece of  paper in front of my face which is where  the headset was and and then I go sorry  excuse me my manager is here what's that  no I can't really know what and then I  get back and I'm like I'm so sorry I  can't believe this is happening but this  just came in from upstairs the one floor  building this came in from upstairs  we're gonna cut the price of those  filets my hat I can't believe we're  doing this I will not stop talking until  you subscribe to my youtube channel  that's right and I could talk a lot  seriously not gonna stop yep still here  not going anywhere I see you don't walk  away from this